what is your read on the present speech
today
we thought it was a speech which talked
to what America must become and I think
the president deserves a lot of credit
for putting his finger on the most
serious problems facing our country and
bringing forth a really important vision
he is absolutely right when he says that
every American must have the health care
that they need I would hope that we
would move forward to a single-payer
health care system which i think is the
only way to bring forth that vision but
I think it's important that he focuses
on that and I think he is right about
talking about the need for opportunity
economic opportunity for all people that
if we're talking about welfare reform we
must be talking about giving people the
opportunity to work and make work more
attractive welfare and I think is also
right about the need to develop a sense
of community in this country where
people care about each other where we
share what we feel and where we stop the
savagery which presently exists and you
cannot stop the violence and safa tree
unless you give people some hope so I
think basically it was a good speech
obviously as they say the devil is in
the details there's going to be an
enormous amount of work to be done which
everybody fear thinks there was a great
speech and they're going to be killing
each other tomorrow on the legislation
which is coming forth but we need
national health care we need a jobs
program we need opportunity for
low-income people we need to deal with
crime I think was a very good speech
represent Bernie Sanders think